[Music]
hello Jasper Johansson postman
mr. Klaus you have a gift you were meant
for making toys so I figure it if you
donate your old toys I'll deliver them
for free tonight I go with you there's
no need for you to come with me really
tonight then
we write a letter to mr. Klaus he'll
make its toy dear mr. Klaus beer mr.
Klaus shall we them yep Klaus what about
me you're you're at your a up yeah sure
you're too far you're gone hey what do
you guys think you're doing
this is smear ins burg the unhappiest
place on earth
and you too can't change that
the postman and toymaker brainwashing
everyone we need to show people that a
true selfless act always sparks another
hi what's happening right now
Oh No what happened I don't work you
just sit there be all magical and
awesome
yes / we're doing it let's go
oh wait wait
time out really that's how you laugh
come on we're running at a time those
kids are counting on us if we don't stop
them tonight this town will never be the
same
destroy those toys
haha Kedar snow they're not attached
why aren't they attached I thought they
were attached I would never in a million
years have done what I just did if I
didn't think these were attached
[Music]